[Música]
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález sigue el remezón
político en bolivia después de la
detención de preventiva por cuatro meses
de la ex presidenta interina jeanine
áñez y dos de sus ministros a quienes la
fiscalía acusó formalmente por el delito
de terrorismo de conspiración y también
de sedición por su supuesta
participación en un aparente golpe de
estado en 2019
sobre el tema se pronunció iván lima el
actual ministro de justicia de bolivia
esto fue lo que dijo escuchemos
en trámite y que ha desembocado en la
audiencia medidas cautelares el día de
ayer al que usted se refiere es
realizado a la señora años en su
condición de ex senadora del estado
plurinacional de bolivia y abarca los
hechos que han ocurrido hasta el momento
que es investido por el general que
alemany con el mando presidencial esos
hechos son un proceso ordinario no se le
puede dar a un ex senador a una ex
senadora en este caso el privilegio
constitucional de un juicio de
responsabilidad es por ese motivo era
necesario llevar un juicio ordinario por
los hechos anteriores a que ella asuma
como presidenta de nuestro estado la muy
señalada organización de los estados
americanos oea muy criticada por su
papel en el manejo de la crisis política
del 2019 expresó su preocupación ante el
abuso de mecanismos judiciales que
nuevamente se han transformado según la
oea en instrumentos represivos del
partido de gobierno solo que dicen desde
washington lo cierto es que la sociedad
boliviana vuelve a dividirse
notablemente los movimientos cívicos los
movimientos cocaleros y también de salud
se tomaron las calles
ciudades del país en protesta por la
represión del oficialismo que dicen que
simplemente están haciendo uso de la
justicia para mantener las garantías
democráticas del país al menos eso dice
sobre este tema se pronunció también
rafael quispe un político boliviano en
la constitución dice que los
expresidentes tienen que tener juicio de
responsabilidad los mejores me pregunto
al ministerio público hasta ahora ha
presentado una proposición acusatoria
hasta ahora ha dicho algo nada porque
sabe por ese lado que en el parlamento
no tiene dos tercios y ese juicio no va
a prosperar por eso hacen las chicanas
jurídicas para analizar este tema
tenemos a dos invitados para el día de
hoy jorge ritter vocero de la
presidencia de bolivia se encuentra en
la ciudad de la paz y también está con
nosotros gustavo pedraza él es dirigente
nacional del partido comunidad se usa
ciudadana y ex candidato a la
vicepresidencia de bolivia él se
encuentra en la ciudad de santa cruz de
la sierra en el oriente boliviano les
recuerdo que ustedes también hacen parte
de esta conversación de este debate
dejen todos los comentarios preguntas
a través de las redes sociales el
recuerdo estamos en facebook también o
se encuentran en instagram y en twitter
como france24
y arroba sant y luego mi cuenta personal
la etiqueta es numeral el debate efe 24
y pues ya tenemos el tema tenemos a los
invitados y quiero comenzar entonces por
gustavo pedraza en la ciudad de santa
cruz en el oriente boliviano como lo
estaba mencionando en la percepción que
hay señor pedraza desde la comunidad
internacional de algunos organismos
internacionales así lo han expresado es
que hay una persecución política en
bolivia cuál es su opinión al respecto
usted lo ha dicho en el hecho de
utilizar la justicia el ministerio
público como una herramienta para
perseguir para reprimir para encarcelar
desnuda la intención que tiene el actual
gobierno han encarcelado a la ex
presidenta lo ha dicho el ministro lima
no merece un juicio de responsabilidades
cuando nuestro ordenamiento jurídico
dice claramente que tiene que haber un
juicio de responsabilidades la última
experiencia hace 40 años dictador
militar rudi garcía meza fue juzgado
porque él sí asesinó el siguen cancelo
gente también fue juzgado como ex
presidente no como general de ejército
él era general de ejército antes de ser
presidente entonces hay desde todo punto
de vista un atropello a la ley hay un
abuso porque la han encarcelado y la han
dado cuatro meses de encierro de
detención preventiva lencia en realidad
constituye parte de un plan de nueva de
una nueva ola represiva que quiere
acallar a la oposición democrática en
bolivia una cosa son los delitos de
corrupción que se hayan podido cometer
en ese gobierno de transición que tienen
que ser juzgados y otra cosa es
transgredir la ley y la constitución
para atropellar los derechos ciudadanos
que están progresivamente nuevamente
después de un periodo corto de
transición volviendo a ser atropellados
con desconocimiento de la ley y con
manejo absolutamente instrumental del
sistema judicial en nuestro país sí
señor jorge ritter en la ciudad de la
paz él es vocero de la presidencia de
bolivia carlos opinión a estos
argumentos la mayoría de ellos de la
comunidad internacional y como veíamos
también algunos partidos de la oposición
que hay una persecución una clara
persecución política en bolivia como
defiende usted esto
buenas noches también un cordial saludo
a quien nos acompaña hoy en el en el
panel es importante señalar que en los
hechos que se sucedieron en bolivia en
noviembre de 2019 una secuencia de
acontecimientos todos ellos entrelazados
con actores específicos y fundamentales
en cada uno de los eventos que todos
ellos concluyeron finalmente con lo que
técnicamente se llama y se denomina un
golpe de estado esto ocurre cuando las
fuerzas y los factores de potter
desequilibrantes de un sistema político
como son las fuerzas armadas la policía
nacional intervienen para incidir de
manera determinante sobre el cambio no
constitucional de quien ejerce la
primera magistratura del estado o la
titularidad del poder ejecutivo aquellos
hechos de noviembre de 2019 significaron
para bolivia primero la interrupción de
una construcción de 37
de democracia en segundo lugar para
sostener a que el gobierno no
constitucional en el país se tuvieron 37
37 muertos más de 800 heridos de bala y
más de 1000 personas detenidas
injustamente sin los debidos procesos
algunos de ellos todavía hoy en las
cárceles todo esto de manera sucinta
expresa que en bolivia hubo una
interrupción de la secuencia
constitucional del país de un presidente
que estaba en ejercicio su manda y
entiende y en la construcción de
sociedad de estado de institucionalidad
democrática estos eventos de ruptura de
quiebre de las de la secuencia
constitucional del mandato
constitucional del mandato popular a una
persona pues no pueden no deben ser
aceptados más aún si éstos han generado
situaciones de muerte como las que le he
mencionado en este se enfrío esto se
debe investigar
para poder dar un cierre
institucionalizado también a lo que
significa un quiebre de la
institucionalidad boliviana lo que el
señor vivanco por ejemplo ha llamado
técnicamente un golpe de estado
señor pedraza el del lado de la palabra
sigo con el señor rector de la ciudad de
la paz que quieren entonces ustedes
hacer con este procedimiento judicial
que ha generado tanta polémica en
bolivia a donde quieren llegar a ustedes
lo que se necesita llegar de forma
institucionalizada es poder cerrar los
eventos que ocurrieron en noviembre de
2019 esta situación de golpe de estado
esto tiene responsables esto ha sido
generado por personas que han prestado
su nombre y su apellido a un accionar
para romper el orden institucional del
país la construcción de la democracia es
un tema complejo y no puede sufrir
interrupciones porque a un grupo
político a un estamento social le viene
bien querer cambiar por una vía no
institucionalizada a quienes tienen el
mandato popular esto tiene que tener una
investigación tiene que ser la etapa en
la cual se encuentra es una etapa de
investigación que dura cuatro meses para
saber quienes quienes participaron de
forma activa en aquellos en aquellas
acciones quienes la organizaron y
quienes determinaron también la el
nombramiento de la señora áñez
presidente del estado cuando la
constitución política del estado
menciona todo el conducto de suscripción
constitucional que camina por una vía
absolutamente distinta de la que se
realizó aquella vez sí señor pedraza su
opinión al respecto hay aquí entonces
como dice el señor reiteró la necesidad
de cerrar un capítulo de inestabilidad a
raíz de un supuesto golpe de estado como
argumenta el claramente
a raíz de un informe que presentó la oea
después de las elecciones presidenciales
de noviembre en donde argumentaban y
decían y evidenciaban que había fraude
en esos comicios presidenciales en un
fraude que beneficiaba al presidente que
buscaba reelegirse evo morales que luego
pues vimos que abandonó el país y generó
parte de esta de este vacío de poder que
vio luego bolivia y lo llevó a esta
inestabilidad cuál es su opinión
bueno la hoya lo dijo con mucha claridad
te lo digo ahora también la bella dijo
que fue fraude hizo un informe el
gobierno firmó un acuerdo para que la
vea haga una auditoría de esas
elecciones la oea hizo la auditoría
emitió su informe el 10 de noviembre y
dijo que había fraude y evo morales
ofreció otras elecciones no se aceptaron
otras elecciones porque el pueblo ya
estaba en las calles el rebelión popular
contra el abuso con en contra el
desconocimiento de la ley contra el
fraude y por lo tanto vino la
consecuente renuncia de evo morales y de
ahí vino un proceso de transición donde
el senado la cámara diputado presidía el
senado eva copa militante del mar y bajo
la presidencia del senado de eba copa y
también la presidencia de otro militante
del más de la cámara diputado se da la
transición y se designa a la senadora
años como presidenta por un determinado
período de 120 días cuando esos 120 días
nos lo alcanzaron para la convocatoria
elecciones
mismo congreso presidido por el
movimiento al socialismo por eba copa
como presiente al senado aprueba una ley
donde prolonga el plazo de vigencia del
gobierno de ella nine año si hubiera
sido golpe de estado si hubiera sido un
gobierno de facto porque entonces
participó de la copa porque participó el
congreso para prolongar ese período de
transición entonces ahí estamos viendo
irrefutables evidencias de la
constitucionalidad de este proceso lo
que no dice mucho del partido de
gobierno es que el encuadre histórico de
este fraude tiene toda su antecedente en
la primera ruptura constitucional que
evo morales- comete el 21 de febrero del
2016 se hace un referéndum para que el
pueblo boliviano apruebe o desapruebe la
elección o la probabilidad de
candidatura de evo morales porque la
constitución ya los prohibía se
manifiesta el pueblo boliviano y se
aprueba el no la mayoría dice que no
puede ser candidato evo morales pero sin
embargo él desconoce
ese referéndum la primera ruptura de la
constitución que comenté o moral y
posteriormente forza una sentencia
constitucional la 0 84 2017 mediante la
cual habilita como candidato
desconociendo el resultado del
referéndum 2 éstos son los antecedentes
del fraude se da en la elección va
perdiendo la moral y ahí es cuando entra
el proceso ya de ruptura se paraliza el
sistema de conteo rápido y sin duda
alguna el fraude se consolida así lo
informa la oea una auditoría y de ahí se
desencadena el lanzamiento popular y
viene lo que hemos mencionado la
transición constitucional señor pedraza
algo de los algunos de los reclamos que
ha hecho la comunidad internacional en
este proceso que ha iniciado contra la
ex presidenta interina jeanine áñez y
dos de sus ministros es que haya
transparencia y que haya separación de
los poderes que garanticen un verdadero
proceso y un legítimo proceso en esta
hoja de ruta que tienen ahora por los
siguientes cuatro meses hay garantías en
bolivia para estas tres personas hay
garantías de las instituciones
llevar a cabo este proceso judicial no
hay no hay porque el sistema judicial
que según la constitución debe ser
independiente o sea la independencia de
poderes que el fundamento del estado
democrático no existe el sistema
judicial está bajo control del
movimiento al socialismo el el órgano
legislativo tiene también mayoría del
proceso es aceptable eso es normal pero
el que el sistema judicial esté bajo
control político del movimiento social y
del partido que gobierna eso es
inaceptable en un estado democrático el
juez no obedece al código no obedece a
la ley
el fiscal no obedece al ordenamiento
jurídico el fiscal y el juez ahora mismo
obedecen a los mandatos del partido
político están alineados al interés del
poder político y en este caso de
represión del movimiento social como lo
fue en su tiempo con evo morales lo que
quiere hacer el partido de gobierno es
silenciar la oposición es debilitar la
es controlarla con el miedo con el
terror porque no tiene capacidad de
resolver los problemas de la economía
no está resolviendo el gobierno del más
los problemas de desempleo de la salud y
por lo tanto distrae y reprimen acude
nuevamente al órgano judicial como
garrote para reprimir y silenciar a la
oposición demócrata el señor reitera su
opinión al respecto
bueno hay que hacer varias aseveraciones
porque ha sido una seguidilla de
imprecisiones y yo quiero por supuesto
estimar de que éstas son involuntarias
vamos a señalar primero el informe la
organización de estados américanos en
las 95 us que lo componen no menciona en
ninguna de ellas la palabra fraude no
menciona en ninguna de ellas la palabra
fraude y el 75 por ciento de la
fundamentación de ese informe está
haciendo referencia al sistema trep que
es información preliminar y el mismo no
tiene carácter vinculante y no repara en
el cómputo final que es lo que
verdaderamente sí tiene carácter
vinculante ese es un primer elemento
junto a una afirmación también que se
acaba de señalar que en el 2019 el señor
evo morales iba perdiendo las elecciones
esto no es real la la discusión de fondo
era si el señor evo morales tenía por
encima del 10 por ciento de diferencia
con el candidato de comunidad ciudadana
el señor carlos meza pero el señor
morales
un momento iba perdiendo la elección
esto también es una es una imprecisión
que estimemos que no se hace de mala fe
la tercera imprecisión que hay que
señalar y que se acaba de mencionar acá
es que el congreso que estaba a cargo de
la señora eva copa fue el que determina
que la señora agnès sea presidenta del
estado para ello hay que ir a la
constitución política del estado el
artículo 169 en su inciso 1º en el
numeral 1 dice que las cámaras se deben
reunir diputados senadores para conocer
tratar aceptar o negar la carta de
renuncia de los presidentes del
presidente y del vicepresidente este
hecho no sucedió en bolivia y tampoco
sucedió que se reúna para tomar
juramento a la nueva presidenta del
estado no se reunieron las cámaras y
está señalado en el artículo 161 de la
constitución política del estado esto
tampoco ocurrió y la señora años tenía
la condición de vicepresidente
segunda vicepresidenta qué es lo que le
corresponde al bloque de minoría org
señalamiento específico del artículo 35
de la cámara de senadores del reglamento
de la cámara de senadores
la señora años nunca podía ser
presidenta del senado porque corresponde
ella tenía representación del bloque
minoritario entonces esto también es
importante señalar y la última
imprecisión que se acaba de decir es que
hay una persecución porque en el país el
presidente y el gobierno nacional no
pueden resolver el tema de salud
desempleo y economía déjeme decirle que
en esta en esta gestión se tiene la
solución se está trabajando y se tiene
implementada ya no es una promesa de la
solución estructural en el tema de la
pandemia que viene a través del proceso
de inmunización en el país que bolivia
ya lo ha comenzado no hay más allá de
eso no hay otras opciones fuera del
proceso de inmunización esto lo estamos
implementando y en el desempleo le tengo
que señalar que el día de ayer en el
periódico el bereber
un medio que no es permítanme por favor
un medio que no es afín al gobierno ha
salido que la tasa de desempleo en
números redondos capas alba se ha
reducido del 11 por ciento al 9 por
ciento está en el periódico el deber el
día de ayer y la economía ya ha mostrado
unos índices de crecimiento por los
cuales el impuesto al valor agregado por
ejemplo ha subido en sus recaudaciones
entonces se pueden realizar un conjunto
de afirmaciones pero la imprecisión
posiblemente obedece o bien a
desconocimiento oa una intencionalidad
política de tratar de generar alguna
argumentación pero que la realidad se
encarga de revelarlas señor señor
richter entonces teniendo en cuenta el
artículo constitucional 169 que usted
menciona en esta intervención quien
debía haber asumido ese vacío de poder
en el que se vio a bolivia tras la
salida de evo morales ya no quiero
discutir si si si hubo fraude si el
informe de la oea está correcto no
quiero ir a ese episodio cuando bolivia
necesita que alguien gobierna el país y
que alguien tiene que asumir las riendas
del estado quien entonces tenía que
haber asumido
a riendas la constitución política del
estado es clara y en el artículo 169
dice que en caso impedimento o ausencia
definitiva del presidente éste debe y
debe ser reemplazado y ahí establece una
línea de sucesión que pasa por el senado
y que pasa por la cámara y habla si las
autoridades las presidencias de estas
cámaras habían renunciado lo que le
correspondía en todo caso si tenía que
hacer algo la señora añeses reorganizar
la directiva de la cámara de senadores
para establecer el cargo ex sucesión y
esto es lo que no se dio por ello
pregúntese siempre usted por ello es que
no se reúnen las cámaras para tratar las
cartas de renuncia para tratar también
la recomposición de las directivas
porque si hubiese no el caso hubiese
este recaído conforme a lo que dice el
reglamento de cada una de las cámaras
en el bloque mayoritario y esto hubiese
señalado que el movimiento al socialismo
hubiese preservado en su poder todavía
la presidencia de esas cámaras y por
supuesto la sucesión
el hecho de fuerza impidió también que
se reúnan estas cámaras impidiendo que
los los parlamentarios pudiesen llegar
al recinto al recinto legislativo y por
un hecho de fuerza también incluido el
secuestro del hermano del presidente de
la cámara de diputados se logró que éste
presentara su renuncia esta es una
situación de fuerza y son un conjunto de
elementos que generan la ruptura para
que la señora áñez finalmente a quien no
le correspondía arrogándose un cargo que
tampoco tenía como presidenta del senado
y lo dice un día antes en la cadena
unitel que ella es presidenta de senado
y en esa alusión evoca al general
kalimán del comandante de las fuerzas
armadas para que intervenga hay una
usurpación de funciones y hay un arte y
está el arrojo
un conjunto de poderes que no había para
los cuales ella no había sido decir al
señor pedraza que dice usted al respecto
entonces bueno hasta carísimo la orden
de sucesión si renuncia la presidente
del senado que le correspondía por la
renuncia de evo morales y del dinero
renuncia el presidente de la cámara
diputados renuncia el primer
vicepresidente de la cámara sanadora la
señora
era la segunda vicepresidente a quien le
correspondía entonces o sea no podía
dejarse un vacío y por eso asume y el
congreso reunido acepta esa decisión la
segunda vicepresidenta ante la renuncia
de todos los que antecedían y
constitucionalmente tenía el derecho a
la sucesión constitucional se apartan
voluntariamente ahí entra la figura la
señora ban es para ser designada pero
todo esto tiene su antecedente
estructural y es el aferrarse al poder
moral les llega desgastado al 2016 la
corrupción creciente la
no me ha disminuida en los precios del
gas y los minerales abajo es eso
desgastan a evo morales como es natural
y en este caso la corrupción es la que
más golpea va a un referendo la gente
rechaza su repostulación y éste por su
ambición de poder si desobedece el
mandato del referéndum ahí está el
origen el origen estructurar la matriz
del fraude está en la voluntad y anti
constitucional y antes popular de o
morales
por eso se comete el fraude por eso se
desobedece el referéndum se esfuerza una
sentencia constitucional se comete el
fraude no encadenamiento de pasos para
quedarse en el poder y ante esa
acumulación de indignación del pueblo
boliviano sale a las calles sale a las
calles y en 21 días logras como nunca
hubo tanta movilización logra una
renuncia una renuncia voluntaria y no
fueron solamente la policía o los
militares quisieron la renuncia fue la
central obrera boliviana la central
obrera boliviana
la defensoría del pueblo muchas
organizaciones sociales le pidieron que
reduce la gente en las calles le pide
que rus entonces no es el pedido de un
grupo militar es una acumulación de
indignación que hay en la ciudadanía
boliviana contra el atropello y eso es
lo que se vivió el 2019 y obviamente ese
proceso de transición donde hubo un
gobierno que cometió corrupción que la
cometió y que debe ser investigado
educados por eso nadie está defendiendo
la gestión y la transparencia que no
tuvo ese gobierno estamos defendiendo la
constitucionalidad y que se respete el
debido proceso que no se atropelle que
no se empiece a atropellar como se lo
hizo en otros años del gobierno de amor
al señor richter usted ha dicho que es
el gobierno interino transitorio de
jeanine áñez es un gobierno que no es
constitucional pero este gobierno fue el
que convocó a unas elecciones en las que
salió elegido luis arce como nuevo
presidente de bolivia entonces estos
comisión no tienen validez
luís arce está usurpando el poder en
unos en unos a través de un proceso
que no es legítimo
lo primero es señalar que esa
interpretación que dice el señor pedráz
es inexistente en lo que hace a la
sucesión constitucional la constitución
política del estado que la tengo que la
tengo acá no señala que la línea de
sucesión constitucional vaya hacia las
vicepresidencias eso es absolutamente
inexistente no tiene consistencia y como
no tiene consistencia por supuesto
después hay que ir hacia otros
argumentos y empezar a hablar del tiempo
pasado para tratar de construir un
relato que avale la conducta que
asumieron las personas que prestaron su
nombre y su apellido para que estar la
acción de ruptura institucional la
constitución y la sucesión
constitucional de acuerdo a nuestra
conducta a nuestro texto constitucional
está absolutamente clara y pasa por otra
vía no por la que se acaba de señalar
lo que usted me preguntaba lo otro los
países han tenido diversos países en la
región han tenido gobiernos
dictatoriales ahí le quiero decir algo
que ocurría en bolivia el 23 de agosto
del año 1972 pues el entonces dictador
hugo bánzer suárez en consejo de
ministros decretó que se apruebe y se
promulgase como leyes de la república el
código de familia el código de comercio
el código pero yo necesito preguntarse
fue elegido en un proceso electoral que
fue convocado por un gobierno que usted
no reconocen como control o que hace
proceso electoral está presente le
quiero decir es que los gobiernos los
gobiernos que no son constitucionales
como el de hugo bánzer suárez generan
una cantidad de normas que se instalan
en el país
aquí el código de familia que ha casado
a muchas familias bolivianas ha sido
anulado no este conjunto de normas
producto de la crisis política conjunto
de normas son la ley de excepción para
la convocatoria a elecciones fue la
solución política para que el país pueda
retornar a la normal constitucional y la
ley 1270 de extensión de mandato en su
artículo 1º
que usted me hable sobre la presidencia
actual entonces un gobierno no
constitucional convocó a unas elecciones
que no son constitucionales y hay un
presidente que está asumiendo el poder
que fue elegido bajo un gobierno no
constitucional
si usted tiene una crisis política como
la resuelve en esa crisis política se
tiene que estructurar una salida y esa
salida es la arquitectura y la normativa
para que se pueda devolver el camino
institucional al país esto es
absolutamente necesario las crisis
políticas se tienen que resolver y esa
resolución hemos tenido la fortuna de
que la asamblea legislativa haya seguido
en funcionamiento para aprobar leyes de
solucionar una crisis no es ver desde un
lado de la moneda que el gobierno no es
constitucional cuando no les conviene
pero cuando ya están en el poder
entonces si es válido el poder que
tienen en ese momento eso sí es un poder
respecto
bueno si usted lo ha dicho es decir una
cosa es una norma especializada y una
cosa de él donde emerge el poder del
presidente arce es decir si ellos
consideran de que ese gobierno juez de
facto de donde emerge todo el proceso
electoral porque se cambiaron los jueces
electorales o sea se cambiaron los
tribunales electorales departamentales
nacional si este gobierno actual dice
que el proceso de transición fue de
facto entonces debería renunciar y
reiniciar de nuevo todo todo lo que
sucedió prácticamente según ellos no
está en el marco de la constitución
política ahí no hay coherencia ahí no
están haciendo no están siendo coherente
es anticonstitucional bien golpe cuando
les conviene y qué es lo que quiere el
más lo que quieren más rehabilitar
políticamente a evo rehabilitar
políticamente su proceso de cambio
mostrarle al mundo de que no hubo
errores de que no hubo corrupción cuando
en realidad sí lo hubo
hubo atropello o autoritarismo hubo
desconocimiento de la
del referéndum del 2016 entonces tiene
que admitir el más de que hubo errores
hubieron falla hubo desgaste y se
salieron del marco democrático entonces
qué tiene que tiene que hacer dejar que
la historia sea la real siga bien te
quieren construir una historia oficial
sobre una historia real la historia
oficial del golpe cuando la historia
real es fraude la historia oficial del
proceso de cambio exitoso cuando la
historia real de fracaso es abuso es
atropello es exclusión de los mestizos
tratando de que el indígena esté en el
centro cuando en realidad sigue excluido
en el campo de la economía entonces la
historia oficial está inventada está
construida sobre la base del poder
absoluto y la historia real la vida de
la gente todos los días y la estamos
viviendo ahora con los atropellos que ha
empezado a cometer el movimiento social
yo richter tengo muchos temas para para
preguntarles pero me queda ya poco más
de tres minutos para para cerrar el
programa quiero hacer la conclusión y
quiero comenzar con usted cuál va a ser
el fin de esta historia este remezón
político que vuelve a vivir
con este con esta envío a prisión
preventiva de la ex presidenta interina
ya nine años y dos de sus ministros
rápidamente también permítame decirle lo
siguiente con todo ese relato de
corrupción y de violación de derechos
etcétera y de fraude y de fraude que
repiten incansablemente un año después
de todo lo que señalan el movimiento al
socialismo obtiene una victoria
histórica de 55 por ciento y el
candidato del señor pedraza el señor
meza que también participó del golpe
estado baja su votación en 10 puntos
mire usted el premio y la contradicción
pero bien el país tiene que cerrar
institucionalmente lo que ha sido esta
ruptura generada por un conjunto de
políticos y de hombres de la acción
política y de la vida social también
empresarial interrumpieron la secuencia
constitucional del país esto
necesariamente se debe cerrar en el
marco de la verdad en el marco de la
memoria y en el marco la justicia y el
debido proceso eso es lo que se está
realizando es una etapa de investigación
debe avanzar para conocer cuáles fueron
las responsabilidades de ahí en adelante
construir la debida institucionalidad y
el reencuentro a los bolivianos
en resumidas cuentas cerrar el episodio
este episodio ya de la historia política
de bolivia y continuar adelante habiendo
dejado este episodio ya cerrado y
saldado su opinión señor pedrosa
primero reconocer la verdad histórica yo
creo que el hecho que se cierre el ciclo
o se siga avanzando tiene que ser de
manera constitucional y en el marco de
las leyes de las reglas del juego
democráticas lo primero que hace el más
asumir el gobierno actual es darse la
autoamnistía se liberan de culpa en
todos los juzgados donde habían
acusaciones por el fraude por los
atropellos por los bloqueos que provocan
muerte por falta oxígeno sin liberan de
culpa a todos y de pronto empiezan el
ataque contra los adversarios o sea que
quieren cerrar el ciclo pero dando
garrote a uno y liberando liberando
sello que se cierre o que continúa la
historia juzgando a los que cometieron
fraude a los que contienen corrupción de
todos los gobiernos de uno y respetando
las leyes respetando los derechos y el
debido proceso todos los ciudadanos
señores gustavo pedraza en la ciudad de
santa cruz de la sierra gracias por
haber estado con nosotros aquí en el
debate de france 24 señor jorge reiteró
en la ciudad de la paz también gracias
por habernos acompañado acompañado esta
noche haber compartido con nosotros su
punto de vista
y viendo la respuesta de la pregunta que
la repetí cuatro veces y a ustedes
muchas gracias por habernos acompañado
en esta edición del debate siga con la
programación de france 24
[Música]